this ship is what independence looks
like in lithuania an aptly named
floating gas platform helping this
country to be the first in europe to
completely cut power from moscow
i feel incredible i feel proud that we
did it on time
and i of course regret a bit that
only this region was caring about
let's say security of supply and energy
independence because probably security
doesn't have a price here they transfer
lng chilled gas delivered from the us
breaking the reliance on pipelines from
russia
after putin invaded ukraine lithuania
also ditched the kremlin's oil and
electricity lithuania's breakaway from
russian energy hasn't happened overnight
it's taken them around 15 years
but the war in ukraine means other
european countries no longer have that
luxury of time
half a century of soviet occupation has
shaped policy here yagita remembers the
fear and force deportations
no family was left unscathed
we know how the kgb institutions have
been working we know how
disruptions of energy supplies can be
[Music]
can be applied so therefore we have a
living memory of
the
strategies that russia has been applying
lithuania's past experience has prompted
massive public support of ukraine and
warnings other european leaders must act
we have to choose sides
and choosing the wrong side in history
is a very big damage for your future why
is it do you think that lithuania
managed to see the writing on the wall
whereas it seems other european leaders
were asleep at the wheel
because it is very convenient to have a
cheap energy
price was important thing another thing
was that europe had too many illusions
about russia we never had those
long-term energy security includes
investing in renewables orders of these
solar panels have rocketed more than 200
percent this year people are determined
to ditch putin's power whatever the cost
everybody agrees to pay extra to have
green power and power produced in in
lithuania at home so
price i think this is not a priority now
safety is a priority
and lithuania's power game isn't over
as this country aims to secure its
energy independence it's determined the
rest of europe should follow
siobhan robbins sky news lithuania